[Música]
ayer en salud hoy en análisis pero
finalmente es la misma persona más
romeros a la que todas las mañanas me
acompaña analizando estos temas de
interés internacional margalida de
mariupol ha trascendido por su grave
crisis humanitaria pero que sabemos de
esta situación vamos a hablar de esta
ciudad en todo este segmento así es es
muy importante porque es una de las
crisis más graves que actualmente se
está viviendo en esta guerra en ucrania
es una situación desesperada alertado
tanto por las autoridades locales como
por las organizaciones humanitarias que
hoy por ejemplo ya dijeron que los
civiles la población civil se está
ahogando dentro de mariupol porque
porque es una ciudad totalmente asediada
por las tropas rusas fueron bomba fue
bombardeada desde el día 1 y luego las
tropas rusas fueron acercando por el
lado y lado actualmente las autoridades
locales cifran en las víctimas mortales-
2.357 aunque oficiales de celenque han
elevado esa cifra a 2.500 aunque la
diferencia no es tanta en la ciudad se
encuentran aproximadamente 400.000
personas con 200.000 residentes
atrapados ahí de los cuales no cien mil
necesitarían evacuación y por ahora casi
no se ha podido evacuar gente habíamos
calculado previamente unas 400 personas
sobre todo a raíz de un convoy de 160
coches que pudieron salir ayer pero hace
menos de una hora llegó una alerta por
parte de la autoridad de las autoridades
así locales en la red de telegram que
decían que al contrario son 2000 los
coches y pudieron salir y que además hay
2000 que están esperando también para
poder salir los la población perdón la
organización de médicos sin fronteras ha
hecho llegar uno de los audios un audio
de una llamada de uno de sus
trabajadores que está ahí trabajando en
mariupol y la verdad es que es
verdaderamente escalofriante escuchamos
lo
hemos visto gente que ha muerto por la
falta de medicamentos hay mucha gente a
100 mariupol hay mucha gente herida y
muerta tiradas en el suelo
los vecinos cavan hoyos en la tierra
para enterrar los cuerpos
suárez light
realmente triste de estos testimonios
mar lo que le provoca a uno es realmente
llorar propuesta hay que tener digamos
un poco de coraza como periodística para
poder informar sin sin derrumbar nos no
hay mucha gente que dice pues que
nosotros podemos dar un poco duros y
fríos al informar la noticia pero pues
es parte del trabajo periodístico
lamentablemente dejar un poco los
sentimientos de un lado para poder
realmente hacer el trabajo a qué se debe
este ha sido tan duro mar pues
básicamente mariupol es una ciudad
estratégica para rusia por qué pues
porque ahora mismo esa ciudad es lo
único que separa la zona de control rusa
en el donbass con la zona de crimea cómo
están viendo aquí en el mapa mariupol
tiene una carretera que va directo hacia
la zona de rusia hacia la ciudad de
rostov del don y también tiene una
carretera que va directa hacia las
capitales de donets y lugares como ven
aquí también no sube hacia las capitales
que ya están bajo control ruso desde el
2014 además también conecta con la
ciudad de sap orilla que también ha
estado bajo ataque pero que todavía está
bajo control ucraniano y gran parte del
problema es que esta ciudad principal
pasa tanto por verde ans como por
melitópol que son ciudades que están
bajo control ruso también aunque ahora
de hecho se ha dicho que va a haber una
evacuación esta evacuación de estos dos
mil coches salió por una zona por una
ruta alternativa que unesa por inia con
verde antes de una por otros lados
aunque también eso no significa que no
tengan que pasar muchos puestos de
control ruso es muy importante también
destacar el papel del mar negro de este
esta entrada hacia el mediterráneo al
final la de mariupol es uno de los
principales puertos del mar de azov y
pues si realmente lograra conquistarlo
sería una gran lanzadera de la fuerza
marítima rusa hacia el mar negro y por
eso entonces es tan difícil la
evacuación desde desde marion por mar
claro por eso es por esa configuración
de las carreteras y por es estar
totalmente rodeada de fuerzas de control
rusa es que es tan difícil tanto evacuar
como que también llegue la ayuda
humanitaria de hecho se dice que hay una
un convoy de ayuda humanitaria de unas
90 toneladas de agua alimentos y también
medicamentos que está en verdiales que
esperando para poder llegar han habido
múltiples intentos pero pues por
desconfianza acciones mutuas de lado y
lado se están diciendo pues que se están
rompiendo los altos al fuego que
deberían permitir estos corredores
humanitarios estamos hablando si sin
embargo de una ciudad que hace más de
una semana de aproximadamente dos
semanas que no tiene agua que no tiene
electricidad con temperaturas bajo cero
en la noche recordemos que ahora mismo
ahí todavía estamos en invierno apenas
hay comida los habitantes tienen que
derretir la nieve para poder beber agua
y pues esa falta de medicinas que
escuchábamos la denuncia de médicos sin
fronteras que no está permitiendo que la
gente están en un contexto de guerra sin
embargo no es la primera vez que mario
poli está en la línea de frente a mar
pues desgraciadamente no mariupol estaba
alrededor de unos 20 kilómetros de lo
que antes era la línea de frente con las
regiones de las autoproclamadas
repúblicas de dónetsk y lugansk era la
primera gran ciudad ucraniana de hecho
que se encontraba ahí una ciudad
mayoritariamente de habla rusa un
importante puerto en este mar de eso que
decíamos antes un núcleo industrial y
que de hecho estuvo disputada con estos
mismos rebeldes en 2014 los separatistas
prorrusas tomaron la ciudad igual que
hicieron con don jet igual con lugar
también como una respuesta a las
protestas de europeístas del maidán pero
a los pocos meses del ejército ucraniano
volvió a recuperar esa ciudad pero le
siguieron meses de conflicto de hecho en
enero de 2015 esa ciudad ya fue objetivo
de un bombardeo en el que murieron por
ejemplo 21 personas es decir que eso
remitió un poco con los acuerdos de
minsk pero esa ciudad ya ha conocido la
guerra y algo importante también de
destacar es que uno de los protagonistas
de recuperar mariupol en ese 2014 fue el
batallón asof del que hemos hablado
alguna vez así es mar bueno muchísimas
gracias entonces por toda esta
información nos vemos mañana con
muchísimo más pasamos a hablar con
nuestro segundo invitado el día